right now for the press preview our
first look at the front pages as they
arrive
over the remainder of the er we'll take
a look at what's making the headlines
with the parliamentary sketch writer at
the telegraph
madeleine grant and wales online's
political editor
ruth mazzansky abba before that let's
take you through the front pages that we
have
starting with the i it leads with those
angry football fans storming old
trafford
forcing a match between manu and
liverpool to be postponed
fever pitch is the mirror's headline it
says that greater manchester
police have launched a probe examining
how manchester united fans managed to
actually break in to old trafford
pressure on the prime minister is on the
front the yorkshire post after the
leader of the scottish tories
said boris johnson should resign if he's
found to have broken the ministerial
code
that story also on the front of the
guardian which says number 10 was
taken by surprise by those comments i'll
bet they were
the express carries the foreign
secretary's comments proclaiming that we
are on the last lap of the coveted
battle
though of course dominic rabb did warn
that some measures may be here to stay
but according to the times social
distancing will be scrapped on the 21st
of june
i mean while the telegraph reports and
speculation that the uk has paid the
400 million pounds debt it owed to iran
which could help secure the release of
the imprisoned aid worker nazidan
zaghari radcliffe
here's the ft it leads with the problems
of businesses that went public
using funding from so-called blank check
companies last year
of the 41 flotations financed this way
only
three are still within five percent of
their opening share price
and on the front of the star the
identity of the criminal genius h
from line of duty is revealed
nah not for me tonight we are joined by
the parliamentary sketch writer with the
telegraph madeleine grant and wales
online's political editor
ruth mazzowski guys lovely to have you
on the program um and tonight let's
start with you
at this arm madeline the front page of
the guardian this story we've been
reporting on all day here
on scan news douglas ross the leader of
the scottish conservative saying of
course
boris johnson should resign if he's
found to break have broken the
ministerial code
i remember a time when there was an
expectation that anyone prime ministers
included
would resign if they broke the
ministerial code
yes indeed and um you know there's
already been the example of pretty patel
having
found to have reached it and not
resigning and you know
there does seem to be a general general
lack of accountability there
um which is which is which is in my
opinion not really seeping through
to the general public as much as it
should i think there should be greater
annoyance about this
but it was actually quite a uh eventful
episode of the andrew marsh show
earlier today some headaches for the
prime minister because as you said
douglas ross becomes became the first uh
senior party figure
to publicly state that the pm should
resign under those circumstances
and it's an interesting story um partly
because i think it
speaks to the the kind of tricky
balancing act that is happening north of
the border
douglas ross and the scottish tourists
are trying to pull off in next week's
elections
you know they know that the prime
minister is not popular there and so it
may
perhaps make political sense for them to
try and distinguish
and distance themselves from the tories
governing in westminster to kind of
create a patch of
uh clean blue water between them but it
could potentially
prove very awkward for the conservative
party down the line if they do find some
malpractice around the renovations of
the pm flat
and actually within minutes on andrew
mark earlier today
dominic mark was already kind of
deflecting and ducking the very same
question that was posed about whether pm
would have to resign so it's kind of
already proving awkward
yeah ruth i mean it makes sense from the
perspective of the scottish
conservatives as madeleine was saying a
bit of
separation but a clear blue water but at
the same time it also makes sense
given the fact that douglas ross and
boris johnson do not get on with each
other i mean he resigned
over dominic cummings didn't he well it
was interesting hearing douglas ross say
today that
um defending why boris johnson hasn't
been to scotland on the campaign trail
he was here last week in wales ahead of
our elections on thursday
by all accounts people were thrilled
with how it went it was on the
appearance i did not
um with ice creams with sand castles and
talking to kids it's everything that
the the downing street machine and the
party machine wants
is boris johnson doing what he does best
the douglas ross to come out today
is incredibly strong um but it hasn't
been reflected here in wales andrew arty
davis
he was the welsh conservative leader has
said he's just not seeing the cut
through on the doors
he says that in those four constituents
he's visited with the prime minister on
monday
no one spoke about it there was no
heckling there was no questions
so it'd be interesting to see if we get
any of that cut through here in wales
ahead of thursday's election
i mean madeleine as we bring the bringer
views of the front of the yorkshire post
and
their headline pressure on the premium
months ahead of ahead of thursday and
they also run that same quote
uh from douglas ross people expect the
highest standards of those in
in the highest office i mean does it
matter
if the public don't give two hoots about
all of this i mean there are rules in
place
it appears that those red at least
appears that that some of those rules
if they haven't been broken then they've
certainly been bent i mean the public
are not
surely the ultimate arbiters and all of
this beyond of course what they can do
when they get into the polling station
i don't think it it just matters in
terms of that you know that ghastly
phrase cut through
what what cuts i don't think that that
is all that matters
um and i think in the long term that the
tories i think that there is an issue
where they
seem to be quite governed by um the
fluctuations of opinion polls and
heavily reliant on sort of focus groups
and so on and i think sometimes they
make quite short-termist
calculations based on what they see in
those polls but i think in the long term
if you do have
a system in which normal rules seem not
to apply in which there was a general
kind of
odour of sleeves about the whole thing
that even if individual incidents don't
have
a huge political impact i think over
time
they begin to mount up and i think there
is that overall sense that people have
and it could create
not just disillusionment with the
government but also i think in generally
in politics so
you know it does matter far more than
just is this immediately cutting through
um ruth just we have to remember that we
have a system in which
the ultimate arbiter of whether or not
the prime minister has
breached the ministerial code is guess
who the prime minister now i understand
that there are some legitimate reasons
for that of course you know he is the
prime minister after all but
but we find ourselves in a rather
farcical situation don't we whether
there isn't the level of
outside scrutiny that you might expect
in for example the private sector
well yeah there's three different
investigations happening now you know
one of those answers going to come
um is a big question if they take
you know they're not going to come
before thursday are they when there's an
election they're going to take a lot
longer than that by which point it's
gone out of public consciousness
people will be will be distracted again
the conservatives have done a very good
job um
and by down the street of of putting
these things off and managing to talk
around them
and same with balance castle you know it
was a huge issue people were really
annoyed about it it was that time in
lockdown
when none of us were seeing our family
our friends um
and we've seen those excuses come and go
and they the conservative party done a
very good job at just batting them away
the question is whether this one is
going to be the one that sticks around
and that depends on what any of those
investigations come back and say
madeline the comment piece in the
financial times is actually kind of
quite interesting because of course
you know what what people want from
their governments is to ensure that we
all have money in our bank account that
we all have the opportunity to be
employed that we all have decent
healthcare and all the rest of it so
the idea that perhaps there is some a
bit of an economic rebound here
one imagines that the prime minister
will be claiming the credit for it
yeah because i think that would
attribute much of that to um the
vaccination rollout which has
you know been a massive joined up effort
involving different areas of government
private sector joining up in the nhs and
you know
the government has made some very wise
strategic decisions that have led to
that which is partly responsible for
you know the economic recovery um i mean
the
the ft has written an editorial just
kind of summing up some of the good news
that we've been hearing economically
recently
they say that the british economy
appears to be recovering a lot faster
than anticipated as we emerge from the
lockdown
and they say that many forecasters have
revised up their predictions for growth
and they've kind of they've lowered
their projections for things like the
unemployment rate
and that's due to things like they say
pent ups demand
people going out there and spending the
flex our flexible labor market
um and a boom in online shopping so
there's lots of good news and it
seems to be um you know a big debate
ranging amongst economists for some time
um especially like in the sort of second
half of last year about what our
recovery would look like would it be
reshaped and recovered pretty quickly or
would it be something more complicated
and the extent to which there's been
going to be long-term scarring and of
course i'm sure there's still a great
deal of
damage to undo um but the situation
certainly appears to be a lot better
than many people have predicted and that
of course
you know i think that really goes to the
heart of perhaps the lack of cover of
these stories i mean ultimately
things like the vaccination and the
state of the economy
that will matter far more to uh people's
day-to-day lives perhaps than these
these kind of um in sort of westminster
i mean it's not just an issue of kind of
westminster squabble but i think
that these things have a macro
significance that goes a lot a lot
bigger than the
you know what are often quite
short-termist rows in westminster
i mean ruth i i mean i don't have the
the kind of the detail of this
particular economic rebound at my
fingertips but when you see
economic recovery in previous occasions
it tends to be quite localized there are
parts of the country that feel it
generally the more metropolitan urban
areas the big cities and so on
and then more rural communities perhaps
don't get so i'm just wondering how the
economic recovery feels
where you are right now it's just
it's a massively mixed picture wales is
a huge diverse area we've got
areas of massive deprivation here
they've recently found out they're not
on the government's list
um for funding to replace eu funding
there's huge questions here about the
economic future
um this is you read this and you can't
help but feel it it looks like great
news
but part of the problem is that we don't
we just have no idea what the future's
going to hold
and the manifestos that the parties are
put out for their um election next week
here
labour's who are in power says we will
continue
several times throughout it they're not
making any big promises on finances or
economy because they say
it's just too uncertain and that's in
contrast with the conservatives here you
were promising a 1.6 billion
relief road on the m4 applied to cumbria
who were pitching
uh decarbonisation and housing so
there's there's a huge spectrum of um
promises coming from the parties when
actually it's hugely hugely uncertain
um on the front page of the financial
time just a couple of bullet points
above this
potentially good news story there's one
that says hospitality sector faces six
billion pound rent crisis
so there's one element where yes it
looks like good news but businesses are
in a really really bad way and
you know no one knows what the future
will hold them another lockdown and many
are won in that one that will definitely
be it those that survived the last three
uh ruth badland we will pause there just
for a second to take a break
but afterwards we'll be discussing this
the angry football fans who stormed the
stadium
and forced a match to be bespoke as next
continue to take you through the papers
um and ruth let's let's go to the eye
the front page of the eye
i have to admit when i started to see
the pictures of this story this
afternoon i did
start to want it did start to worry
slightly manchester united fans have
long been angered by their americans by
their foreign owners the glazers
i have to say i don't think the actions
such as this are going to do very much
to persuade them to sell up their
controlling interests
no they've been under pressure for years
there's been huge public protests
i think this one feels slightly
different in that it's come off the back
of the asl
um a ferrari a few weeks ago it's also
the the different element of it is that
the fans got into the stadium you know
the
the security elements of it will be you
know looked at in great detail for weeks
and months to come
and i think it's interesting what gary
neville was saying today which is that
he's saying
that fans have had enough and he says he
backs the fans here
he says that all football fans should
unite behind what manchester united fans
have done today
um he is hugely critical of the state of
um old trafford and carrington the
training ground and he's saying that
actually if you've got these um big
money owners
they need to be doing more to support
the club and he's scared him that
blazers aren't doing it and fans have
just had enough
i mean madeleine ruth is clearly correct
i mean the fans have had enough but i
mean
isn't the genie somewhat out of the
bottle and one have to i have to say i
mean sky of course my employer
have played their part in and putting
lots and lots of money
into the game it does feel like if money
remains the driving force particularly
for the bigger clubs
you know the idea that you're going to
see a german system where you have 50
plus one and fans have a con
have some kind of saying all of this i
mean that's for the birds
yeah that's a really good point i mean i
i certainly wouldn't claim to be
any sort of an expert on on football but
it does it strikes me that
another genie that's sort of out of the
bottle is is the the way that it was
quite remarkable just how quickly
the european super league kind of
crumbled you know in in the face of
overwhelming
fan fury um the plans for this thing
that were in motion where there was you
know great deal of money
investment at stake and a great deal of
people heavily involved in it
and they've had to basically claw it
back because the surge of fury from the
fans was so great that they couldn't
really do anything else
and i think that's real you know that's
clearly really empowered
um the fans who were protesting today um
and i suppose i would be
i wouldn't actually be surprised to see
um just
disgruntled fans at other clubs now you
know as you say but
making further demands um on that basis
and sort of
trying to recapture their own game that
they feel has been
taken over by foreign corporate
interests
um with a final word from you on the on
the the daily express front
page uh dominic rabb telling us that we
are on the last lap in terms of our
battle against covet and it certainly
feels like that
wandering around my neighborhood at the
moment but the idea that we may have to
wear masks
after june i mean i'm not surprised by
that are you surprised that there is a
degree of surprise
um i don't see how people could be
surprised really i think that because
the different the roles are different
here in wales
arthur's minister has told us repeatedly
he thinks masks and social distancing
will be in place until the end of the
year
i think there's more surprise here in
wales hearing what's coming out of the
uk government
corridors which is that everything could
be lifted in a month and a half's time
like you it's been lovely walking around
cardiff this weekend the sun's been out
the bars are back open the city has come
back to life somewhat
but we're far from over with this
i mean madeline i don't know about you
but i've got bank holiday monday off the
weather will be absolutely horrible for
it but you know
to be able to go out to have a bit of
food to have something to drink to see
friends
you know i'll stick on a mask i'll stick
on two masks three four five
yeah i mean i think i feel like you i'm
pretty relaxed about mosques
you know i would dislike them to be part
of our long-term future but in the short
time they're
more of an inconvenience and they might
might conceivably be good for business
if they give
people who are still nervous the
confidence to get out there after a year
of being cooped up but
you know that wasn't it wasn't the only
thing that the foreign secretary hinted
at in his in his interview he was also
talking about
um potentially social distancing
remaining in place me that's a very
different kettle of fish because for
some industries
anything involving live performance
hospitality that's potentially
existential the extent to which it
um caps the number of patrons that you
can have at a venue
so while the masks thing is is uh you
know i think we would all be prepared to
kind of go along with
that if it was a precursor for getting
our freedom back which is just you know
so exciting after
a very boring time but social distancing
is a very different kettle of fish and i
think they need to establish
what exactly is going to be happening
there